[Music]
last month I became the first talk show
host in the history of the medium to
have his own blimp which was huge for me
[Applause]
it was on the East Coast covering the
the baseball playoffs and when the
baseball playoffs ended the plan that
TBS had was to what they said retire the
blimp I think they were going to take it
to a field and just let it go
I didn't know what was gonna happen I
found out that they were gonna get rid
of it I was horrified I was furious I've
never had a blimp before I wanted the
dream to continue so at great personal
expense I arranged to have the blimp fly
out to the west coast these things don't
travel quickly at left the East Coast I
think a month a foot go home and it's
had some setbacks a light mist put it
down for a month some butterflies
attacks it at one point but I'm told
it's due here any time the blip is gonna
be here what's that it's outside your
people a woman with a fake beard in the
crowd is telling me that our blimp is
outside we have a camera outside let's
get a shot of the blimp it's here
[Applause]
[Music]
oh yeah I'm so glad you noticed it you
know I don't here's the problem I don't
know what the coolest thing is it is it
the music that's making it cool or is it
the blimp itself cuz it's got this
majestic music let's take a shot of the
blimp with different music and see if
it's still cool
[Music]
[Applause]
it's cool yeah now it's like smoky and
abandoned it
it's running liquor one can of beer at a
time
[Laughter]